last year gordon tried to turn around
restaurants across the country in a
moment you'll see how they're doing
today but first a look back at what
sante la brea was like just a year ago
located in the heart of hollywood sante
la brea felt like a good old-fashioned
situation comedy there was the wacky
owner dean
his two sons sammy and arthur who think
dad has completely lost it i took him
out i'm not putting him back [ __ ]
even if i'm [ __ ] wrong
do it
there's mark the general manager with an
embarrassing problem
i don't like wearing deodorant what can
i tell you
[Music]
and lastly there's the grumpy chef
aurelio i can do whatever i want here so
stupid
what the [ __ ]
but sante la brea was no laughing matter
as this restaurant was failing miserably
what's the problem with the russians
straight off what is it everyone takes
advantage of me i'm not really making
money i'm actually spending money for
last year when it came time for a
healthy sante la brea lunch gordon was
horrified this restaurant prides itself
on being healthy that does not look
healthy and they are disgusting thank
you
[Music]
uh this here is a mobo dofu and then
came the dish which gordon would forever
identify with sante la brea
this is a turkey didn't know to do for
me [ __ ] in chinese that's for sure
how was it just in terms of the
presentation it looked like a dog's
dinner
then you get to taste it
it's hideous so
oh god
jesus
oh not that bad show me where the salmon
is it was smelling fishy dean was
clearly in denial but the one thing he
couldn't deny was what gordon found on
an inspection of his kitchen hey rotten
your food is about as healthy as these
vegetables when i smell [ __ ] i i go
straight for the [ __ ] juggler
there's nothing for music the biggest
problem this restaurant
is you
congratulations
it's a [ __ ] disgrace
[Applause]
[Music]
clearly santa labrea had many problems
but the one thing dean had going for him
was his two devoted sons i'd see the
tears for me dad i really want to cry
can you help me show me some love let's
see some let's see some some following
[Music]
as customers came in for dinner that
night
orillia was in the kitchen doing what he
normally did
ignoring date just listen to me go to
the back don't stand here i want to stay
here and you're going to do what i'm
asking just do it
as for the customers they weren't very
happy with what aurelia was doing either
one no we're not very happy
no right
minutes later chef ramsay unveiled
another shocking discovery
and what is that
steak duck
fight duck
after the last unhappy customers left
there was one important matter that chef
ramsay had to deal with right away if a
health inspector had witnessed what i
witnessed just in one of the fridges
bang game over clean this [ __ ] pigsty
this place
does not deserve an a
and the only thing you're getting from
me tonight is that
an f
there
they're staying on
now move your passes the staff clearly
got the message and pulled an
all-nighter cleaning santa la brea inch
by inch
[Music]
satisfied that santa labrea was now
clean gordon turned his attention to the
food two specials on the menu tonight
yes first dish is a halibut we're gonna
cook it in the marinade second dish
salad of shrimp local shrimp it's really
nice to see chef ramsay be able to take
his genus aqua and bring it down to our
level like we're doing ghetto gordon
but gordon was not done
moments before dinner service he shocked
the staff again
dean
yesterday
there were some serious infractions in
this restaurant yes
serious do what you have to do
sir put your hands in front of you palms
together
[Music]
you're not touching anything tonight
you're going to tell them exactly what
you're doing
run your business vocally
you're not getting arrested you silly
billy hey relax look at him he's about
to cry
okay first table just about to arrive
let's go
dinner service started well because of
gordon's new specials we have a spice
halibut which is marinated in fresh
yogurt but it didn't take long for mark
to damp in the evening
mark who's tricking again oh no he's a
lipkin
do you guys have a reservation stamp it
down or dry or absorb i don't know it's
all leaking over it oh my god oh
[ __ ]
[Music]
gordon please send them home since i
don't need your [ __ ] memory stops the
[ __ ] has to leave
gordon ordered mark to run home and
change his shirt
secret made for lady strong enough for a
man
[Music]
after another up and down night at sante
la brea gordon still pushed forward with
his plan to relaunch
he brought in crews to give the place a
complete makeover
here we go outside patio right coming
through look
no
dirty white curtain fresh shades hand
painted blinds new benches oh this is
[ __ ] comfortable bed
what a vibrant
sexy healthy change awesome i moved to
tears so much he's a brilliant man
that's really cool
[Music]
chef ramsay then unveiled a new menu
that was not only healthy but tasted
great as well the menu absolutely
crucial when you come into something
healthy
and vibrant
oh jesus christ
dad got really emotional when he saw the
new menu i'm so happy to see my dad
happy it's fresh and if it's not fresh
it's not on there i'm happy for you you
deserve it and your sons deserve it
thank you man
[Music]
everything was in place for a successful
relaunch halibut wonderful
sea bass until dean pushed a little too
hard in the kitchen just hurry up a
little bit i need the food out do it
fast you really want to leave
look keep in mind what i say okay what
what i'm kidding my gosh hey god damn it
stop it goodbye
[Music]
[ __ ] out of my life i'll do it
[Music]
[Music]
with the restaurant packed with
impatient customers and no chef in the
kitchen relaunch night was about to turn
into a complete flop where is our
grilled cheese in our hummus but aurelio
had second thoughts and came back to
apologize to chef ramsay come here
okay no no but listen listen come here
this is important this is launch night i
can't bend the [ __ ] you do care don't
you yeah i bet you're on my life i
listen i listen to me at least pay me
the rest of the money that's all you
[ __ ] care about i'm not gonna be in
you i gotta have sex i'm not gonna work
without faith okay how much money you're
owed you owe me a hundred and forty okay
here
no no no no no come here there's one
hundred okay the rest it comes after
service
please
i am gonna do this tonight because of
him okay thank you
thank you come here calm down
big deep breath yeah the crisis was
averted and the kitchen caught up and
relaunch night was a hollywood hit look
at it it's beautiful and i really like
the sauce and the vegetables
dean was thrilled thank you very much
thank you
and so was chef ramsay because this
restaurant was one of the toughest
turnarounds ever
now it's time to see how santi la brea
is doing today i'm here at the scene of
hollywood's biggest flop last year sante
la brea now this place gave me a
headache an even bigger stomach ache so
i'm back to see if this hollywood story
has a happy ending
[Music]
when chef ramsay goes to work on any of
the restaurants he always does a
thorough kitchen inspection and while
some are absolutely fine others are a
disgusting mess
here are the three worst inspections in
kitchen nightmares history
number three fiesta sunrise a mexican
restaurant in west nyack new york
what's that the burritos what's that one
the chicken of the enchilada oh what's
that that was the granby
ground beef half of its [ __ ] fat you
idiot
it's fatter than you
what's that
the bin oh how
it's like a cement mixer
ladies and gentlemen
i'm so sorry
but we're stopping service
number two seascape inn a family
restaurant an islip new york god when
was the last time this place was cleaned
oh [ __ ] oh my gosh
what is that
so that's the pesto
i had for lunch this is 10 000 times
worse than i thought it would be
how dare you cook me a lunch out of this
kitchen right to the wall you dirty pig
this is disgusting
i'm closing it down
[Music]
and number one dylan's an indian
restaurant in new york city
it's beyond disgusting
i killed somebody
what is that is that for rats or mice
food for the catcher there so we have
got rats here
that is all over the place
oh my god look i've got one in my
[ __ ] hair it's cockroaches boxes full
of them
oh my god look there they are there oh
[ __ ] hell oh my god
look at that
there you go
now back to sante la brea whose kitchen
was no treat for chef ramsay either
rotten but another huge problem with
this restaurant was the owner dean you
took a [ __ ] order don't [ __ ] do it
he lashed out at everyone including his
two sons arthur and sammy
[ __ ] even if i'm [ __ ] wrong
do it and then there was mark the sweaty
manager who really didn't know what to
do
stamp it down or dry or absorb i don't
know it's all leaking over oh my god oh
[ __ ] it was a difficult turnaround
but chef ramsay left santi la bree in
good shape for the future
it's a year later time to see if this
hollywood eatery is still in the
spotlight ah santa labrea last year they
gave me some of them made me sick the
russian manager had bo and i had to
bribe the chef not to quit let's see if
these guys have finally got their act
together
good morning good morning gordon welcome
back good to see you man
you're looking good you're looking fresh
how are you good to see you buddy well
i'm passings these are good things have
been improved since last year and uh you
know where is that
my father retired pass it on to us
overseas he's in syria basically he's
overseas i'm shocked if there's one
thing that was a concern for me when i
was here is just the level of anxiety
and yeah i suppose stress definitely
over stress did i ask where is he
ah
where he's in the back
no he's not in the back no no mark mark
has uh has we put him out the pasture
big time mile's gone as well i do not
miss mark at all not for a second not
for an ounce of my being
nothing arilo's gone all the cancer the
[ __ ] the shift's gone as well oh yeah
the guy was one of the many cancers that
we had infecting this whole place i'm
pleased to see you both standing strong
more importantly the fact that the
business you know is surviving we're
doing very well we'll have a quick look
around yeah quickly go to the bathroom
thank you
now they may never see mark again but i
certainly do we went to bloody hell and
back him and i
hello hi mark is gordon
how are you i'm very i think how are you
listen i'm slightly shocked the fact
that i've just returned you're not here
can i um meet you in five or ten minutes
i know you live locally yeah
okay good now just to keep it under
wraps will you call me when you're two
minutes away so i can come out and meet
you
[Music]
the chicken comes in fresh i guess this
is extra
why are you lying
first thing that hits me with the labels
labels and dates look at the floor the
floor's clean enough to bloody eat off
it no fear at all gordon walking into
the fridge i wanted to show him how
organic and how clean everything is
well done huh
oh two seconds i'm just going to get
this
hello
hi
okay okay baby two seconds one minute um
so nice to talk to you
[Music]
what a surprise what a surprise ah first
of all it was good to see you why did
you leave there was a little dissension
between all of us um i didn't ever have
the respect back after that um i was the
bite of the joke did you miss working
there yeah i missed the people it was
nice i would have liked to have taken
your menu and ran with it you're still
sweating
look oh wow we're not even working he's
tall sweating so what are you doing
apart from sweating besides sweating i'm
working for a company right now that
does raw food because i am into raw food
birds
is there anything you wanted to say to
me now that you didn't get a chance to
say last year give me a job
say that again give me your job
i thought that when you came along that
maybe god delivered you yeah yeah yeah
so
hold on hold on hold on hold on do
something about your sweating first and
then they think about it it's like
niagara falls on your eyes
thank you good to see you look after
yourself
[Music]
chef ramsay's revisit to santi la brea
has been full of surprises shocked
goner mark the sweaty manager and
aurelio the belligerent chef but the
biggest surprise was dean
who moved to the middle east and left
the restaurant to his sons
wanna first met your father i felt that
it was on the verge of a nervous
breakdown don't eat don't drink don't do
anything here this is not good okay
whenever i see that i'm gonna be festa
i don't think we could we could really
be committed 100 while he was still
around because even if we did try to
make decisions and if we even if we did
try to implement our own ideas he would
just go over our heads and change things
can we call him yeah really
but i'm sure he'll get up to talk to you
[Music]
you're dead there we go thank you thank
you and dean it's gordon how are you i'm
fine thanks gordon good listen i'm so
sorry you're not here but more
importantly how have you been i've been
fine very well i
you know i appreciate you coming over
again
i think the boys are doing a great job
and i'm sure you're gonna be incredibly
proud of them when you come back and see
what they've done
there are good boys i appreciate your
advice to me i've done exactly like you
asked me to i need to take a break i
think dad's very proud of us absolutely
i mean the fact that he can actually
leave and
go overseas and chill with his family
for a bit and leave the place with us i
think he's very very proud very happy
and one more thing i want to say before
we go maka dufu
bye-bye now
[Music]
so
business uh month on month in from this
time a year ago where are we i could say
about 10 better so you're up 10
considering the recession
so who replaced mark don yeah got my
girlfriend in there she is your witch
you lucky man right see nothing
no i'm good i hope
salmon's cooked beautifully nice and
pink oh my god
i told my chef make this one [ __ ]
good
that is delicious
really good
now this is a asparagus dish ginger in
like a vegan tofu cream sauce
i've never been a big fan of tofu
we've managed to make it delicious it's
soy protein soy protein and sugar on
chicken exactly i can't believe you
bastards made me eat that you think that
anyway i'm telling me you'd want to eat
more wouldn't you but not only that i
just said it's delicious which is
delicious
i wanted to wait to you you took a
couple bites
you're happy with that one aren't you
yes we pulled the uh we pulled the
master
honestly i'm very proud and more
importantly the fact that dad's out of
it and you know less stressful you can
come back here one day and enjoy the
fruits of his labor yeah and your
talents keep it going
if it wasn't for born we'd probably be
out of business
i can easily say that
all done good to see you
guys thank you so much
take care yes
well done
sammy and arthur are well on their way
they have a great location great healthy
food and more importantly a manager that
doesn't sweat all over the menus a
hollywood story with a happy ending
now it's time for a quick update on finn
mccools
[Music]
chef ramsay first visited them a few
years ago buddy and his two sons were
going bankrupt
there was no significant improvement how
long could you afford to stay open for
we're in trouble right now the food was
a disaster always the sign of a very
insecure chef when he macerates
everything in possible vinegar they had
no customers
why don't more locals you know come
maybe they've come here and had a bad
experience and didn't want to come back
jason had no hope i'm worried every
night going to bed are you gonna be able
to pay this mortgage
i can't describe to you how stressful
that is and brian had given up in the
kitchen i'm done working here in one
week chef ramsay not only changed the
restaurant but the family's attitude as
well
[Music]
last year when chef ramsay returned we
found out that buddy maintained all the
changes and business boomed business
how's it been the last 12 months we are
up average across the board
35
great buddy was finally making money and
brian was a changed man you sound so
confident brian you know that we're
having fun it's great unfortunately
buddy suffered a heart attack but is now
doing fine this year another new
development for the mazzio family a
buyer made buddy an offer he couldn't
refuse
he turned a significant profit and he
gives all the credit to chef ramsay we
did everything he said
and
he was spot on buddy is now doing work
as a private investigator as for his two
sons they both remained at finn mccool's
i love my brother to death jason is
still charming customers at the bar
and brian is still the chef and
impressing everyone with his food
perfect
now it's time to update you on
giuseppe's but first let's take a look
back at what this restaurant was like a
year ago
located about 30 minutes from detroit
this italian restaurant was not only
failing badly it was also tearing a
family apart
how many times you looked at me and said
hey good job not once this won't tell me
about it
joe the old school dad and his 28 year
old son sam were at each other's throats
why can't you show me the same set of
balls that i had and just go up there
and try to make something out of it i
feel that you sometimes you hate me and
wife and mother kathy was caught in the
middle i'm tired of playing referee i
don't want to be everyone's mom on top
of that joe's health was failing and he
was too stubborn to slow down
when gordon first arrived he had a
sample of the menu
jesus christ
like a mouthful of hubba bubba and it
soon became clear why this restaurant
was being shunned by the locals
can't really identify any flavors
because it's just absolutely piping off
almost like it's been nuked in a
microwave for three minutes
[Music]
that eggplant bland milky spongy chef we
got probably three thousand respond that
we did this questionnaire and we didn't
get one negative thing about the food so
where the [ __ ] are they then
i don't know all you do is find me
[ __ ] excuses don't [ __ ] me and i
won't [ __ ] you do you understand yes
that night chef ramsay was back to
observe dinner service how are you today
go ahead how are you hi how are you my
name is carol
knock them off
[Laughter]
looks like a cockatoo
in the kitchen chef ramsay was horrified
that the microwave was cooking more than
the chefs how could they be raised
potatoes in the microwave that's the
program here so just happy once has he
lost his [ __ ] marbles just minutes
after customers ordered food
you ready honey oh yeah i would like to
expand meat
subpar food was flying out of the
kitchen food comes out quick is that
normal really quick too quick i think
unfortunately as fast as the food went
out that's how fast it came back reorder
sauce is warm but the inside it needs to
be warmed up this is supposed to be
black and it wasn't black and that's all
fat
the restaurant's engine room the kitchen
was a dysfunctional mess why don't we
ever add cows in this line there's a
towel right there i won't even wipe my
ass with that there's towels right there
it's all down here
joe
did not like
what the hell how's that steak on that
redo you want me to cook it doesn't come
out of my ass okay all right i hope it
doesn't come out of your ass
don't touch this thing
what the hell
sam get you us out of there
[Music]
with emotions between father and son
still raw chef ramsay tried to mend the
relationship it's sam a good chef
he's he he likes to cook
you don't put enough time here to get
involved the way she'll fire in your
belly
i mean what can you show me the same set
of balls that i had and just go up there
and try it to make something out of it
i've been [ __ ] doing that [ __ ] since
i was [ __ ] 13 nice to you you don't
see me you don't see me see what tim
rubbish scrubbing floor is nice i've
been wanting you to [ __ ] notice me
for how long i don't know how many times
you looked at me and said hey
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] good job not once this
won't tell me about it
the next night to bring order to this
kitchen and avoid more fighting gordon
made sure everyone had specific roles
you're going to be expediting it now and
you're on the line yeah yeah good good
man but joe couldn't confine himself to
just expedite don't overcook his ham
it's just
just moments later joe was back at the
stove doing what sam was supposed to be
doing joe
are you expediting no not really
i can't read without my glasses your
glasses around your neck
[ __ ] it i don't like the estate guy i
don't like it it's what nothing tam it
looks like [ __ ] with gordon's
encouragement sam finally worked up the
courage to stand up to his dad tim yeah
kick him off fast i'm sorry dad but your
[ __ ] sugar's up you got to get off
thank you
[Music]
late that night gordon's crew worked
around the clock to turn this restaurant
into a modern italian eatery come
through
look at this
is it beautiful
it was claustrophobic now it's a modern
contemporary italian restaurant
oh my god he's holding sammy he's just
born
when i saw my father look at the
pictures of me and him when i was a
little boy
you know when i saw tear come to his
eyes i almost lost it is it lovely
now that the restaurant had a
contemporary look chef ramsay designed a
menu to match it's fresher it's quicker
it's smaller and more importantly it's
10 times more exciting the classic soups
pasta violin minnesota soup that's the
heartbeat of the restaurant if this
restaurant's got chance of survival
we've got to communicate
and stick together tonight right now i'm
so excited i feel like i'm 18 years old
again okay one two three
on relaunch night
[Music]
welcome to the new giuseppe's tractor
everyone was feeling optimistic i'm
ready to rock and roll
but within an hour sam was buckling
under the pressure what's wrong it's
rock oh [ __ ] he and sous chef ryan were
falling behind and their standards
started to drop we waited an hour for
our food now i'm sitting here 20 minutes
waiting for raw fish making matters even
worse ryan was not taking the relaunch
seriously if i was rich sure the hell
wouldn't be here
chef ramsay was having none of that okay
and try to get the kitchen back on track
so just quit the [ __ ] around you'll
see a difference in the standard come on
guys i know we can do better you're
[ __ ] here we can do better come on
let's concentrate
yeah sure but sous chef ryan clearly set
in his ways couldn't take the criticism
you know who i blame i blame all this on
you
it's not difficult it's not making
[ __ ] pathetic excuses get back in
your [ __ ] truck right coming to me
looking for excuses excuse me i got no
excuses you just said you blame me in
the [ __ ] oh yeah when i first arrived
that's cool thanks chef
huh what a [ __ ] idiot
where's brian
with relaunch night heading towards
disaster joe returned to the kitchen to
support his son come on i'm not giving
up i'm not [ __ ] giving up all right
sam
audrey marcelo is coming right now
and for the first time father and son
worked harmoniously as a team and the
knight was saved
yeah you have to try this it is so
delicious
[Music]
yeah you did an excellent job today sam
but before chef ramsay would say goodbye
there was one more thing he wanted to do
i asked all of you to write a letter
and before i go i want you to read a
letter
kathy
joe please try to trust in sam
you need to teach and support him you
need to let him make mistakes you need
to pull back
dear dad i really truly only want you to
be proud of me
i really am sorry if i disappointed you
even more sorry if i hurt you
i love you dad
amazing
through sam he made me realize how
important you are
to me
and i came to realize
that you are ready
[Music]
i want you to take charge
p.s
i never stop loving you
and i'll be there for you no matter what
happens
love you dad
[Music]
you're an amazing family
you've just forgotten it
now it's time to see how the family is
doing today
i'm back at giuseppe's macomb township
michigan a family-run italian restaurant
the only problem was the family were at
war with each other the food was about
as italian as a microwave pizza had they
turned it around we're about to find out
kitchen nightmares has seen its share of
arguments but we've selected the three
biggest blow-ups
with number three which took place at
peters in babylon new york
where peter took his anger out not on
chef ramsay but on a bill collector
come on you [ __ ]
[Music]
number two goes to sebastian's in
burbank california where this owner had
trouble facing the truth i've never ever
ever ever met
someone
i believe in as little as you and he
literally chased chef ramsay down jeff
gordon
jeff gordon where the [ __ ] are you
where are you i'm here you coming to my
restaurant yes i'm just so [ __ ]
disappointed you gonna
like men you're going to speak to me
like a man
you didn't listen to what you're not
listening to what i'm saying did you
just hear what i've just told i'm
stepping away from you because i don't
want to be too close you ungrateful well
you have no idea you have no i [ __ ]
idea joker [ __ ] you and the number one
spot goes to secret garden in moore park
california where gordon had seen enough
of owner michelle's antics my food been
putting the best chef in the inventory
connie what no i'm not getting no
[ __ ] i'm just hiding [ __ ] okay
let me finish i'm pushing my finger
[ __ ] hands up here listen to me you
were like a pig
you french pig you're not happy i'm
[ __ ] happy you can get out go on you
can get out [ __ ] yourself you can't get
out my [ __ ] kitchen yeah is it
where's your [ __ ] kitchen and
cleaning you lady [ __ ] no
there was plenty of fighting going on at
giuseppe's family-run restaurant but
they weren't taking on chef ramsay they
were battling each other i've been
[ __ ] doing that [ __ ] since i was
[ __ ] 13 nice to you you don't see me
see what sam it took tough love and
plenty of tears but chef ramsay managed
to turn this place around and bring a
family back together i never stopped
loving you
and i'll be there for you no matter what
happens
love you then
now one year later gordon's back
giuseppe's was very close to my heart
when i got here the restaurant was in a
complete mess
before i could start fixing that i had
to repair something much more important
and that was the relationship between a
father and a son is a year later and i
hope they're not back to that old
fighting ways
please god
[Music]
come on my donnie i'm good you're great
it was good to see ramsay always makes
me excited
good to see you it's great to see gordon
again he truly loves
our family it's busy which is good news
um more importantly have you been
good well up and down you know like uh
the economy here in michigan is bad and
yeah we tried all that on our own yeah
so who's in charge of the kitchen so
yeah sam yeah have you left him in
charge or are you interfering i i
interfere in the point where if it gets
backed up you know
some things never change
why don't we ever add thoughts in this
line there's a cell right here i won't
even wipe my ass with that there's
towels right there it's towel down here
right i'm gonna quickly go and see the
man yes right i'll catch up with a
minute where is he
some of the best salmon i've ever had
hey big boy
hey how are you so i saw chef ramsay
poke his head in there and you know i
just want to almost jump through the
window and give him a big hug
absolutely good to see you great to see
you and where's uh where's brian
ryan yeah no he
go
like [ __ ] for that yeah he's nothing but
trouble no dad is he on your case is he
i'm not gonna sugarcoat her my dad's my
dad who's that's how he paid your
compliment
actually uh two days ago that's great
news yeah so it's getting better through
age i find it a lot easier now to be
able to talk to my dad more because of
one marcelo i'm ready to go on it's a
lot easier i guess uh to open up and
share each other's feelings how many
times a day using the microwave
very very rare i've been keeping the
standard as high as chef ramsay's
standard would be i'm dying to taste
your food all right yeah i'm dying to
make you something good to see thank you
thank you my wife
let's have a catch up uh really good to
see you danny thank you take me from the
top what happened after i left
we boomed i mean we boomed yeah
reservations every night it was great it
was really good come january we just
tanked yeah i mean i have customers
coming in now all the time you know i'm
sorry we miss you but we're laid off i
have never seen the economy like this
how's joe been he had a little
complication due to the diabetes but he
battled back i'm proud of him he's
stronger than i thought i'm scared of
the diabetes i'm scared that my
husband's only 55 and may look older
than that i'm scared that he won't be
able to enjoy his retirement someday
i'm scared
and the relationship between joe and sam
excellent i mean it came from nothing
almost no relationship to a solid
father-son relationship sam doesn't live
with us now so it's nice it's better no
who lives at home just me and joe just
you and jeff
for a couple more weeks did you meet for
a couple more weeks
it's gone we lost the house
[Music]
so we need to find a place to live oh
sorry it's okay
that's okay really i can sleep anywhere
yeah
so we're we need to uh they foreclosed
we have a few more weeks and i need to
find a place to go
jesus christ when i told him about
being homeless in a few weeks
i actually saw a tear in his eye
like he really truly cared i've never
met
a woman as strong as you involved in
this business and you are a rock and the
family depend on that rock and you'll
bounce back and i know you're getting
that house back oh i will i'll cry a day
and life goes on yeah the only the
source of income that we have in the
troy area is the automobile industry
so that goes down everybody around the
area goes down so yeah it's really
really bad hold on to this here
yeah this is stabilized as i can it
really hurts to watch your parents
struggle
these are the people that's worked
their asses off for their their whole
life you know and they don't have
nothing to show for
it sucks just one year ago this family
was in a constant battle
fire in your belly
now even with the economy weighing
heavily on giuseppe's joe sam and kathy
are closer than ever
looking at what you were like this time
a year ago how
emotionally destroyed it was fragmented
rottweiler one side yours on the other
side
a year ago i was afraid to leave them in
the same room together i was afraid
there'd be bloodshed as long as we're
together nothing else matters who made
those sam
it's crabbing shrimp tortellini wow
that is delicious okay
in your eyes now is he a cook or is he a
chef he's a chef he's definitely a chef
food like that and what's this this is
the stuffed pork chop look at my
father's recipe with roasted rosemary
redskins and fresh uh vegetable melody
i'm being spoiled here last year
best and worst moments i think the worst
moment when when you were here last time
is when my father got frustrated because
the orders were coming back and he told
me to you know get off my station
don't touch this thing
what the hell
sam get dressed out of there
not the best
no and when you asked and if he was
expediting and uh he said no not really
i can't read without my glasses your
glasses around your neck
[Music]
and best moment probably the letters
because i was genuine and it was from
the heart
much needed
dear dad i really truly only want you to
be proud of me
i really am sorry if i disappointed you
even more sorry if i hurt you
i love you dad
you know we got together as a family you
know that was the best thing now a
little surprise um ladies and gentlemen
can i just have your attention with 30
seconds i'm going to welcome now two
very important gentlemen please yes from
the italian american chamber of commerce
to present to the family of giuseppe's a
plaque
please
in recognition of your commitment to
honor the italian heritage we're pleased
to present this plaque to you excellent
thank you
[Applause]
for authentic american cuisine well i
felt you know like uh somebody got a
golden globe you know
little speech
what
first you come in you tell me you like
my food it's an honor thank you i'll
treasure this the rest of my life it was
nice for me to see him beam and shine
and be proud
the single most important thing that
gordon did was to get my son and my
husband on the same page respecting each
other loving each other he gave him a
relationship they were lacking gordon
taught me you know that the family is uh
is everything so even if we don't have
the house or maybe somebody will have
the restaurant we got the family we have
the strength
only a month after gordon's visit the
borgias decided to close down giuseppe's
the bad economic times especially in
michigan made it difficult to keep the
restaurant afloat the borgias plan on
looking for new opportunities once the
economy improves in michigan and
although giuseppe's is no longer in
business they will always be grateful to
chef ramsay for it's because of him this
family's bond and love for each other is
stronger than ever
you